>>David: Traditional classrooms, the
kinds that I certainly grew up in,
really don't reach every child.
Not because of teachers, not because
of anything the teacher's doing
so much as the actual
physical structure of the room.
The idea that children
learn best by sitting
in uniform rows facing the front
of the room, has been known
to be ineffective for some learners
since the 1300s, as a famous painting
that shows what a real
classroom looked
like at the University of Bologna.
And when you look at it, you laugh,
because there's students sleeping,
there's students talking to each
other, and there's the poor professor
in the front of the room
trying to give a lecture hoping
that everyone's learning something.
So our motivation was to say if
the structure of the classroom is
at fault, what new structures could
we design that might be better?
>>David: My name's David Thornburg.
And right now we're
located in Recife, Brazil.
But we also live in the United
States, and we split our time
between the two countries.
My background is in science and
engineering, mathematics, education,
and in particular, the role
that technology might play
in support of students learning.
The Holodeck, which takes its
name from science fiction,
is basically an empty room that
can become anything you want
when you turn the computers on.
So walls, which are normally white,
can suddenly become
viewports into outer space.
They could become views
out of a submarine window.
They could become almost
anything based
on what the computer
software is telling it to do.
The Holodeck is based on the idea
of inquiry-driven,
project-based learning.
They're actually engaged in
a mission, and the outcome
of that mission is unclear.
And a consequence of that is
the students are so engaged
that they tend to remember what
they learned in that environment
for a far longer period of time than
most kids remember their learning
in a traditional classroom
environment.
The first mission that we created was
a Mission to Mars to explore whether
or not Mars has or had life.
Interesting question.
Scientists are unclear.
I really like having students
explore things for which tools
like Google can be a terrific
resource, but that they're not going
to provide a closed answer.
If people already know the
answer, and it can be looked
up on Google, why ask the question?
Let's ask them real questions
that scientists are asking
themselves these days?
And that gives them a sense
also of the reality of science.
It's messy.
It's unclear.
There are differing points of view.
What I see happening now, though,
is a consumer-driven revolution,
in that the students
themselves are taking control
of their informational tools.
Students are bringing their
own smart phones to school.
They're bringing their own tablets
to school with every expectation
that they will be allowed
to use these devices in
the school's network.
The challenges that
I see are two-fold.
One of them is students may know
how to use these tools mechanically,
but it doesn't mean that they know
how to judge the value or accuracy
of the information
that they're finding,
and they need responsible
adults to teach them.
If you start with four levels
of data, information, knowledge,
and understanding, data and
information are the sorts of things
that Google can provide for you.
Teachers don't have to
provide that stuff anymore.
Historically, they
provided a lot of it.
But how nice to liberate teachers and
say, "Now, you can focus on knowledge
and understanding, that's
where the real payoff comes."
I've been telling kids that in 1492
Columbus sailed the Ocean Blue,"
why on earth waste time
presenting that, but instead focus
on what were the kinds of challenges
that Columbus had with his crew
to entice them to go
beyond the site of land?
Now that's a very different
kind of question.
And one that teachers don't often
get to ask, because they spend
so much time on the trivial
stuff that can be looked up.
The value of the question for
the kids is it gets them thinking
about topics in a deep way.
If history teachers only get to spend
time teaching the rough outlines
of history in terms of events,
the meaning behind those
events is amazingly lost!
To me the real power of technology
in the classroom comes when we use it
to do things we couldn't
do before at all.
Not just to do old
things differently.
So technology is important
in education to the extent
that allows them to
achieve educational goals
in some powerful new ways.